[Music]
you have had so much success you've done
so well for yourself in the last year or
two and then this this high honor
bestowed on you you were asked to sing
the national anthem at dodger stadium
yeah which i would think would be real
nerve-wracking it was horrible um
are you are you a singer i'm not a
singer i'm not a singer and uh you could
tell
right
i think it was pretty obvious yeah i was
so nervous i went because i'm like a
comedian you know and like when you mess
up as a comedian people are like what an
idiot
that guy's funny what a clown but this
time everyone was like take this
seriously
like all my friends our nation's anthem
yeah all my friends were like oh you're
gonna blow it you're gonna blow it
my friends thought like they're like
we'll take it really seriously like i'm
gonna like whip out my penis and start
jiggling around like a total
degenerate scumbag which is what i
thought initially but then i said take
it good to edit those thoughts yeah
you could put it in the chat okay that's
enough
[Applause]
i didn't know about it yet
i'm out of here i could stretch i
stretch after an event like that they
also told me i i'm not a a singer and
they were like well just make sure you
hit it in a c sharp and i'm like
very cool
yeah
i'm just going to start low and and or
and then get high that's a tough song
well i
watched it my favorite part is at the
end you give this insane confident kind
of creepy look to camera were you aware
you were doing that i was trying to
stare in the soul of america at that
point let's check out this you'll see
what we're talking about look at this
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
i don't know i love that yeah i think we
got that stare you are defying
i don't you were that was [ __ ] the
haters yeah that was for the haters out
there
i had no idea that that voice that could
come out of my body i sounded like a
six-year-old like black jazz singer
scavenger